Hi, Hannah!
(audience claps and cheers)
Okay, I have read your book.
I am obsessed with it.
I literally, I have it like dog-eared
and annotated.
One quote I wanna read that I really loved from an explorer,
Robert Swan, that you were inspired by.
And he said, "The greatest threat to our planet
is the belief that someone else will save it."
Indeed, that's one of my favorite quotes.
And I think it definitely resonates with me
in so many other people as well,
because, I think we rely on other people
to solve our world's issues.
But, we don't have to wait.
And for many of these issues, we don't have time to waste.
So, it's so important that we all do our part
and also take action on these issues.
Well, let me ask you a business question,
business woman to business woman.
So, when you were 10 years old,
you wanted to save this horse farm
that was like taking care of rescue horses
and you raised the funds to help these horses
and you in your mind thought, "Oh, that's funny.
'Cause all of my peers are really into the
American Girl doll, Saige,
who happens to ride a horse."
And you thought about bringing that in.
Where does the business side of you come in
to start correlating how to inspire people
about the environment
through things in their everyday world?
Like an American Girl doll?
I didn't really think about it much
as a business at the time.
You know, it was just fundraising, doing my part
for my own community of this local horse farm.
And, it was a movie night fundraiser,
so we showed the Saige movie from American Girl doll,
so we knew that if we promoted it more
and had something that would entice people to come,
we'd raise more money.
And so, I've been trying to incorporate things
kind of like that in the work that I do, you know,
targeting towards your audience
to kind of draw people in more to my message
and so that it really resonates with more people
and you can have a greater impact.
Okay, what is something that we can do on a daily basis?
Well, Drew, that's a great question.
Of course today is Earth Day
so there's many things you can do.
Of course the obvious is refusing single-use plastics
wherever possible.
Those are plastic bags, straws, cups, utensils, and bottles.
Even just trying to buy more secondhand
reduces the carbon footprint that we have.
But there's also a business standpoint
and a legislation standpoint that we also have to address.
And, as individuals, oftentimes we forget
that we can have an impact on that.
Whether that's signing petitions,
reaching out to these different CEOs
or even reaching out to our Representatives
to support environmental legislation,
they all have such a great impact.
What is the thing you're doing with Starbucks?
I'm desperate to know.
Yes, back in 2018, I was part
of the Break Free From Plastic campaign
to try and really convince Starbucks to invest
in a sustainable coffee cup.
So we put pressure on them on social media
and collected over 1 million petitions
and pressured them into investing in
new sustainable coffee cup
and they agreed to do so.
Okay, I just wanna thank you so much for coming here
and educating us on our show.
And for more amazing ways that people
are changing the planet around the world,
Check out our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
We're also gonna be featuring this book.
I highly suggest everyone run out and get it.
It's a quick read, but man,
is it a thoughtful thing that will stick with you.
(upbeat music)